[Musique]
1994 année cruciale dans l'existence de
l'ukraine tout juste indépendante le
pays renonce à son arsenal nucléaire et
les ukrainiens n'était pas attaché à
leurs armes nucléaires il était attaché
à la reconnaissance par les pays
occidentaux de l'art existence une
rétrocession accepté sous la pression
des états unis et du kremlin en tout
cent soixante seize missiles
intercontinentaux et mille cinq cents
ogives nucléaires sont cédés à la russie
donc pas important pour la sécurité en
europe a été franchi et commente la
france en effet l'ukraine troisième
puissance nucléaire mondiale renonce à
son arsenal en contrepartie du soutien
financier
nous sommes réunis aujourd'hui pour
supprimer le dernier problème découlant
de la guerre froide la petite phrase de
boris eltsine lors de la signature de
cet accord ce matin illustre bien la
politique russe fin de la guerre froide
pas vraiment selon anne de tinguy dès le
début des années 90 il ya des tensions
entre la russie et l'ukraine et des
tensions qui ne vont en définitive pas
cessé pendant 30 ans 1 malgré ces
tensions l'ukraine voit en ces armes un
formidable moyen de pression échangerait
bombe atomique contre manne financière
l'ukraine a accepté sagement de
démanteler son arsenal nucléaire
elle est récompensée la russie lui offre
gaz et pétrole l'amérique lui tend la
main soutiens économiques et logistiques
pour ce pays ruiné de l'ex urss mais
aussi et surtout une reconnaissance de
son intégrité territoriale
autrement dit de ses frontières un
accord confirmé par la signature du
mémorandum de budapest quelques mois
plus tard là où il ya un bémol c'est que
tout est bien sur le plan politique mais
il n'y a pas
d'engagement
contraignant si par hasard ces garanties
ne sont pas respectés et bien
lorsqu'elles n'ont pas été respectées
c'est à dire lorsque en 2014 la russie a
annexé la crimée et qu'elle est
intervenue quelques semaines plus tard
dans le donbass eh bien
l'ukraine n'a pas pu obtenir que
référence soit faite au mémorandum de
budapest volodymyr et lens qui a aussi
déploré le non respect de ces accords
comme en février dernier lors de la
conférence de munich sur la sécurité
sa vie de mon vont vite très trop où cia
de renom potentiel ou krajina autres
frenchies
brouillonne à ce niveau
[Musique]